[Música]
actualizamos la información de la
economía con Juan Pablo lucomín Juan
Pablo saludo para usted nuevamente acá
estamos otra vez Ángela esta vez
empezando con noticias de América Latina
porque la noche de este lunes fue
aprobado un polémico proyecto en Chile
sobre extracción minera Así es el
polémico proyecto se llama Los bronces
integrado y este pretende ampliar su
yacimiento en la Cordillera de los Andes
y requiere una inversión inmensa un plan
al que ambientalista se ha mostrado
completamente en desacuerdo previamente
nuestra corresponsal en la capital
chilena nos dio más detalles sobre este
proyecto
por unanimidad el consejo de ministros
del gobierno de Gabriel boric dio luz
verde a la ampliación del proyecto
minero en los bronces integrados que
pertenece a la minera global
angloamericana que supondría una
inversión de 3000 millones de dólares
para mantener y ampliar la vida útil de
este proyecto hasta el 2000-36 y
mantener así su producción de cobre lo
hace sujeto a una serie de condiciones
Como por ejemplo que angloamérica se
encargue de compensar el 150% de las
emisiones de este proyecto reemplazando
por ejemplo hasta 70.000 calefactores de
leña en la región metropolitana por
otros que sean menos contaminantes
mientras que para los ejecutivos de
anglo American esto abre la puerta a una
minería mucho más sustentable que deje
una menor huella ecológica esto ha sido
valorado muy negativamente por decenas
de personas y varias agrupaciones
ambientales ambientalistas que critican
el proyecto como nefasto dicen que no se
condice con un gobierno ecologista y
feminista y afirma que afectarán a las
cuencas hídricas de la región
metropolitana y Valparaíso donde se
sitúa el proyecto y que son dos de las
más afectadas por la crisis hídrica que
se vive el país también temen por los
glaciares Aunque el proyecto contempla
un sistema de alerta temprana de estos y
también evaluación y monitoreo de los
valores de este gran activo
medioambiental entre tanto Juan Pablo
otra noticia importante de hoy es la del
crecimiento económico de China el dato
se conoció así es y sorprendió a los
mercados pero algunos analistas han
dicho que no ha superado los datos pre
pandémicos todos estos datos Pues que
llegaron después de que china pues
amplió o abrió sus puertas después del
confinamiento estricto que tuvo y vamos
a ver específicamente el producto
interno bruto en este primer trimestre
en el en el dato anual llegó al 4,5% y
superó con creces la previsión que
hacían economistas de afp que era el
3.8%, la producción industrial este dato
también anual en el mismo primer
trimestre 3,9% este fue un menor de lo
que se esperaba del
4,4% y las ventas de minoristas que este
es el dato que nos dice que las personas
están saliendo a comprar a las calles
que los comercios están abriendo y este
sí fue del 10,6% desde la previsión del
7,5% sin embargo aunque son datos que
han sido optimistas las básicamente los
analistas dicen que pues no todavía
superado el dato de antes de 2020
escuchamos lo que dijeron las
autoridades chinas con el anuncio de
estos datos teniendo en cuenta que la
base afectada por la epidemia en el
segundo trimestre del año pasado fue
relativamente baja la tasa de
crecimiento económico en el segundo
trimestre de este año puede ser
significativamente más rápida que la del
primer trimestre pero también debemos
ver que el entorno internacional sigue
siendo complejo hay incertidumbres en el
crecimiento de la demanda externa
Todavía existen restricciones
insuficientes en la demanda del mercado
interno y los precios de los productos
industriales siguen cayendo la
eficiencia empresarial todavía enfrenta
muchas dificultades la ONU hizo
previsión sobre la economía de
Afganistán y la revisaremos porque el
organismo predice que la economía de
este país se contraerá la inflación
aumentará y la liquidez caerá si la
inversión en ayuda internacional
Presenta una caída del 30%. la ONU dijo
que la economía Afganistán ya está en
problemas y su pib podría reducirse en
un 0,4% este año todo esto la
advertencia a lo que pues los donantes
Dejen de mandar dinero por la crisis
económica global que como hemos visto
hay inflación generalizada entonces pues
dejan de enviar dinero a este país
indicadores por favor vamos con Los
indicadores las bolsas asiáticas
cerraron en terreno mixto y ni el
principal indicador de Hong Kong ni el
de Tokio llegaron al 1% en sus ganancias
las bolsas europeas Siguen operando con
los principales indicadores de Alemania
Francia y Reino Unido con ganancias y en
Latinoamérica tenemos cuatro indicadores
el de Argentina esto en cuanto al cierre
fue el 2% para Brasil tuvo el único que
tuvo una pérdida y Colombia y México
también tuvieron ganancias por encima
del 0,2% y para el cierre su cifra del
día en 1.100 millones de dólares está
valorada la empresa Hong Kong Network
más conocida como hkvn que ofrece
servicios que incluye banda ancha y
administración de WiFi y podría ser
comprada por china Mobile Próximamente
ya esperaremos que pase Gracias Juan
Pablo y mañana nos vemos con mucho más
pues acá lo espero